Let's go ahead and recap some of the things that we talked about.
One, we talked about profiling concepts, types of rendering, concepts and thread profiling.
We looked at calling concepts, calling methods, GPU visualizer, GPU draw thread, CPU draw thread,
analyzing those draw calls and looking at Unreal Insights.
From there we looked at optimization visualizers, using those visualizers, quicknotes,
lumen, nanite, and even some pro tips with those.
We also looked at nanite and virtual shadow maps, why to use them in an overview of what they do.
We then looked at reviewing understanding LODs.
And in that we looked at how to edit your polygons using the poly editing tools, swapping out geo, merging, and even HLODs.
And from there we finally looked at texture and material optimization, looking at how to optimize your textures,
the tools we have, as well as materials.
Overall, I hope you've enjoyed this course and found it very interesting and helpful.
And let us know if you have any questions. Thanks again.